so this is Cleo and as you can probably
immediately tell Clio is an awesome dog
she's one of the nicest dogs I've ever
met she loves people anyone that'll give
her any food pretty classic dog stuff
and she also happens to be missing her
right leg she was found on Petfinder
after she spent some time as a stray in
Oklahoma with injuries from unknown
causes now hanging out with Cleo and
just playing with her like you'd almost
forget like you wouldn't even know that
she's missing a leg because she's just
running around chasing stuff playing
fetch loves being outdoors all that
classic dog stuff but although she
appears super healthy now dogs that are
missing Limbs and any pets that are
missing limbs are actually more likely
to have things like arthritis and joint
problems in their other limbs later in
life because they're compensating for
the missing limb so she's running around
being awesome now but it would be ideal
for her long term to be supported so
that's where this company called 3D pets
comes in so they reached out they were
telling me they have a particularly
high-tech solution to the problem and
asked if I basically want to go see it
and it turns out it is pretty sick I
mean I've already talked about this
before but there's Tech in everything
like every story every angle everything
I see on the news nowadays it has some
tech in it but even this story surprised
me at just how much how much Tech was
involved in helping dogs like Cleo
so it's this multi-step process first up
is the scan so the pet comes into their
Studio which is actually in New Jersey
pretty close to our video studio and
they actually use a smartphone to 3D
scan the animal so the idea is to take a
few scans they actually use the iPhone's
lidar scanner or use the true depth
camera system or both this isn't exactly
what they were designed for but with
apps like combed and hedges it is a
pretty clever solution for just basic
measuring so basically once you get
clear to hold still for long enough you
can get a pretty decently accurate scan
of her Dimensions you know how high off
the ground she is how far around the
shape of the prosthesis what that needs
to be
Etc and all this is to be used in The
Next Step which is 3D printing the
prosthesis which is crazy now you might
be thinking like I was at the beginning
of this wait a second why is there so
much Tech being used in this process
like why is it 3D scanning the animal
and then 3D be printing the prosthesis
what's going on here and the real answer
as they explained it to me basically is
because every single animal's situation
is a little bit different no two are
exactly the same whether it's the reason
that they lost the limb or part of the
limb but then just like the size of the
animal how big are they how far off the
ground does the limb end how much weight
are they going to be able to put on it
all these different things are slightly
different for every single animal kind
of like a fingerprint so clearly you
can't just Mass produce one like one
size fits all prosthetic obviously even
with humans you know this is already
true but the idea is you want it to be
as custom and bespoke and comfortable
for every single animal as possible so
this 3D printing process allows for
rapid reiteration and making a couple
different versions till you get it
exactly right and so this is why they're
doing it this way 3D pets in particular
they've worked with over 300 different
animals so far at their Studio they
actually start with a candidacy Forum on
their website but then once they get
going they have a ton of of options to
date they've done many dogs as pets but
also some ducks a tortoise a pig they
had a goat recently that was missing
part of its skull that didn't form
properly and you know goats like to use
their heads for Stuff obviously so they
made a helmet for him and one elephant
leg recently so anyway Clio scan pretty
straightforward and within five minutes
they have a couple decently accurate
models to work with and then they import
it into the computer to move to step two
so how do you get the scan off the phone
well that's the easy part we get the
scan up the phone onto our our web
portal which we're able to bring into a
custom design software here where that's
really where the magic happens right
where we're able to take a design and
really mold it to the 3D scan of each
pet so that we can make sure
everything's fitting perfect so this is
clio's scan right and the appropriate
fit as it would be built on the scan
right so you can see the scan overlaid
and and you know we can patch things up
as needed it's almost like 3D Photoshop
in a way but then we're able to control
the lattice where the hardware mounts
where the straps go we can really
position everything perfect to each pet
and then once we're happy once it's set
then we bring it into another software
where this is where we optimize it for
printing so we have to be able to
basically give the printer instruction
on on what to make so this is where we
really fine tune the intricacies and the
detail of each layer because again we
want we want some areas to be nice and
rigid we're Hardware mounts for example
but like around the rib cage around the
the lungs we want the flexibility so you
can see we don't have that thick lattice
there this over here these Wings we can
really easily Bend even if the dog
fluctuates in weight we want it to
accommodate those changes but where the
mount is where the hardware is on this
end this we want to be really sturdy and
strong because that's where the impact
is so once we're happy with this once
it's ready to go well take it over to
one of the 3D printers and leave a whole
bunch of different sizes depending on
the case depending on the animals so
okay but they're all pretty similar in
how they work so 3D printing to be
perfectly honest I never really cared
that much about 3D printing this is like
a confession like I I never I there was
a ton of hype about it and obviously a
lot of people care a lot about it but
every time I was brought up to me I
couldn't really find a reason to care
and we got a 3D printer at the studio
and you know we've printed a couple
random trinkets here and there mostly
things that are just like useless stuff
just to see if it'll work you know
whatever neat but this is the first time
I've seen a situation where 3D printing
clearly makes the most sense for a
manufacturing process obviously you
can't do one single mold you can't do
one size fits all so like I said this is
it just made the most sense for once
they have a couple different size
printers in here ranging from something
like an Anker M5 something you might buy
on Amazon all the way up to an
industrial sized one the size of a
refrigerator basically to work on
different sized pieces for different
animals so once they were happy with
clio's design of the prosthesis in the
software it hits the printer and about
literally 24 hour hours later it's done
it's printed the whole thing now this is
the final step for hers there is still a
sanding down process to soften the
corners and make it as comfortable as
possible and also in 3D printing there's
commonly these support pieces that you
get when you print oddly shaped objects
that need to be cut off and they're
actually working on ways to melt that
down and use it in other things like
wheels or feet so they can actually be
resourceful about that as well but
they've showed me a bunch of examples of
various shapes and sizes of things
they've printed for animals in the past
so this one is just about ready to ship
out this dog has a residual limb so we
have this build out here and we we do it
like this so that we can keep the weight
bearing load right below where the limb
used to be yeah if we have it in any
other place they just won't be able to
walk correctly and this is also now
softened down and it's just sanded
basically we do a sand and torch okay
yeah so we'll basically burn the
material back like what the machine is
doing heating it up to a melting
temperature it Smooths it out and
something that we're very well known for
with our devices are our feet and so one
of the biggest things is when the dogs
are taking steps you want that foot to
be able to compress to absorb that
impact yeah I'll trade you
I think this is version like five or six
of the foot okay and we're on version
like 10 or 12 of the harness so they're
constantly changing and adapting you
know if somebody reaches out to us and
they say I burned through a foot here
are the reasons why we're gonna make the
changes of the foot so that stops
happening uh and so that's why we go
through our variations we're actually
working on the next version of the foot
which has uh rounder edges so more of a
radius on these edges like a tire maybe
yeah yeah exactly like a tire because
dogs tend to lean on one side of the
other and we'll typically have the
owners flip it around once they start to
wear on one side so it wears evenly
entire rotates exactly right yeah a foot
rotation that's funny and then behind
you we have some of our carts that are
in process too yeah so this is one going
down to a dog in Texas she's got two
deformed limbs in fact one is really not
formed at all but she's got one deformed
here on the left hand side so we make
Provisions for that so that the
shoulders can still move around so this
will get three six inch wheels on each
corner and then this this is another
good example this is for a dachshund
that has one full remaining leg and had
a partial amputation and so the owners
didn't want something extremely bulky
but they wanted that front leg to have
support because dachshunds have a lot of
back problems yeah so we designed this
specifically for this case where the
Dachshund can put its legs and move it
and still have the support on the outer
edges and we still have our flexible
harness here
and these the wheels can change camber
as well too so depending on sport mode
yeah yeah and we'll go up to eight or
ten inch wheels I think you saw this one
that Escalade dogs
we should do Spinners on one of these
rooms one of these things honestly
that'd be amazing you know we actually I
I haven't put it past people the woman
that we did our original dachshund cart
for she saw her black wheels and she was
like I'd like silver rims please and I
thought she was joking I totally thought
she was joking and I was like oh that's
a cool idea she's like no really I want
silver Wheels would you paint it or
would you we ended up painting it yeah
yeah so all right Clio scan was pretty
good then they designed her prosthesis
around that scan that went great then
they printed it sanded it and torched it
down and matched it with the leg for her
height the only step left now is to see
how it works so what I kind of didn't
realize is it's not just like you
attached the prosthesis to the dog and
then they just magically start running
around perfectly like they've had it
their whole life but no like anyone
who's had crutches knows this there's
actually an adjustment process as you
get more and more used to it so I got to
watch Clio sort of learn in real time
even in just these few minutes go from
hovering it off the ground to eventually
starting to trust it and the process of
them getting used to it depending on the
pet is basically to introduce them to
more and more time per day with it so
that they eventually get used to totally
living with it maybe 20 minutes a day at
the beginning then it's an hour a day
then two hours a day and you slowly see
them start to remap their muscle memory
and unlearn walking without the limb and
really trust it and depend on it by the
end so at the end of the day I thought
this was super cool and it basically
it's a huge win for pets like Cleo and
it's also super cool that it's enabled
by Tech that feels relatively accessible
like the phone in our pocket a computer
app one or two pieces of software and
then 3D printers like all things that we
can get started with that's how they got
started with building this studio in New
Jersey and actually helping so many pets
and they actually now will continue to
evolve this there's other places around
the country in the world doing the same
sort of thing but you know they they
potentially can do remote Creations for
pets that don't come to the studio but
they get to like send a mold in and then
build a prosthesis for other animals
they don't even get to see I'm not even
going to pretend to be an expert on 3D
printing or prosthesis but like
hopefully this helps more animals sort
of extend their lives and live more uh
freely I think is the right word these
pieces are typically priced from 100 a
couple hundred bucks to up to a thousand
or two thousand dollars and ideally will
last a lifetime at least if they've
stopped growing so thanks to 3D pets for
letting me pull back the curtain a
little bit into how they use Tech to do
what they do thanks to Clio for letting
me hang out all day and thanks to you
for watching
see in the next one peace
[Music]